لم يدخل للمحاكمه مكبلا ولم يخرج منها الى
الزنزانه معنويات ترامب جيده كما هو دائما
هذا ما قالته محاميته رغم مواجهته لاكثر
من 30 تهمه من بينها دفع اموال لاسكات
الممثله
عام 2016 فكيف يمكن ان تنقلب اول محاكمه
لرئيس امريكي في التاريخ لمصلحته ستزيد من
شعبيته وسيصبح بطلا لمؤيدين هذا ما قاله
خبراء مع بدء محاكمه ترامب فبحسب استطلاعا
للراي اجرته شبكه
76% من الامريكيين يعتقدون ان السياسه
لعبت دورا في قرار اتهام ترامب خصوصا مع
اعلانه ترشحه للانتخابات عام 2024
محاميته قالت ان ترامب مستعد للمحاكمه
وبالتالي قد يلعب مع فريق دفاعه على
تكتيكات وقد تستغرق المحاكمه شهورا او حتى
سنوات وحيدها قد يكون ترامب رئيسا
للولايات المتحده في الدستور لا يمنعه من
الترشح للرئاسه مع استمرار محاكمته صحيفه
الجاردن قالت حتى ان كان مذنبا ومن
المحتمل ان يحكم عليه بالسجن فهناك عقبات
خطيره امام دخوله للسجن فالتهمه التي قد
يحاكم بها ليست خطيره ظاهريا لوضع رئيس
سابق وراء القضبان